hey it's Evan and today I don't have my
usual set of wheels so I thought it
would test out using a Zipcar which I've
never tried before had a membership for
a couple months but haven't used it so I
signed up for the one near my office and
I have to go pick up my son of all the
zip cars available the only one the
website says is free is this minivan so
I'm stuck with a minivan I brought my
car seat with me to pick up my son he's
four and the first thing we're supposed
to do is look over the car and see if
there's anything wrong with it
any damages or scratches they sent me
this emails what I'm supposed to do on
my check-in but I kind of forgot what
that was this is a couple months ago so
I thought I'd just try it out and see
how intuitive it is and we'll see what
happens so everybody gets a card so this
is my zip card here my name isn't on it
but I have an ID there at the bottom and
what you're supposed to do is on the
front there is a little the card thing
here you put the card on and that's
supposed to unlock it I didn't hear
anything but let's see if it unlocked it
worked
haha okay so I'm gonna hope it only
unlock the front door so let's go in
unlock everything I'll take the car seat
and pop it in and we'll loose fasten it
when I get there close that up get in
now I'm inside very exciting it is hot
in here and apparently I think the keys
are supposed to be in the dash here so
let's pull this up and see uh keys are
non the - this is for gas so you can put
the receipts if you need to buy gas if
you if it's under a quarter tank you're
supposed to buy gas so where are the
keys ah I see something down here let's
take off my sunglasses I can see better
so it looks like they're oh oh that's
cool that's this little string here so
the keys won't go away and you can't
take them with you so I guess the unlock
lock always happens with the with the
card because I can't take that off okay
let's try it up put it the keys in it
starts I hope I have more than a quarter
tank of gas Wow
all right way to start the day with a
headache there okay
so I've got half a tank of gas so I
should be good for the day I am using it
for two and a half hours I've booked it
this was the only one available I'm
going to crank up the air conditioning
here because it's hot Maxx AC we're good
alright I'm going to drive off I'm gonna
go pick up my son and we'll report back
soon I just arrived at my son's school I
turned off the car and I'm hoping that
if I take out the keys I can still get
back in the car I'm thinking my card
unlocks it but I don't have that far to
go just in case I'm just gonna pull them
out and maybe leave the door open just
in case here hopefully it doesn't auto
lock on me let's get out let's go find
my son make sure the car seats still
good yeah I'll have to fix that when we
get here but let's go get them see what
he thinks about the car
there is come on in can you open it we
have a new car today you want to see it
this is the car what's in my hand this
is a look look look like this says
zipcard oh you don't care now hi I just
want to see the car this is the car what
do you think is it good it's pretty big
huh no your sight is on the other side
okay that can be your side let's get in
get in get in see your car seat do you
know how to get in here okay I'm gonna
put you in the car seat we're gonna go
and for those of you watching you like
it yeah we'll fix it we'll move it you
want to move it to this side okay can
you move it by yourself woah yeah okay
I'm gonna help you we're gonna go home
okay
okay so I got back in the car everything
it did not lock on me I have my keys I
can put them back in we could start up
again my son is sitting in his chair do
you want to say anything what do you
want to say love you we love you too
high-five oh oh there you go okay we're
gonna start up and away we go home
alright I'll report back when I'm
dropping off the car okay we just
arrived home I'm going to turn off the
car I spent about we're gone for like
two and a half hours I'm gonna take it
to the shop soon first but Hayden what
do you think did you like the car what
did you like the car yeah should we do
it again yeah you're making jumbled
words okay let's get out let's get out
we have arrived okay here we go let's
get out here's the house everybody this
is my place nice sunny day let's get the
man out of the car oh you found your own
way out okay
you want to wave right at the camera
blow a kiss blow kiss all right we'll
see you soon can you close it by
yourself and good job all right we'll
see you soon
you